this movie doesn't just jump the shark
it jumps the whole Sharknado
[Music]
so fast
installment of The Fast and Furious
franchise which has gone from Point
Break with cars to if I'm not back in
five minutes call the president family
so the plot of this movie is I feel like
it's the plot of a few of these fast
movies there's someone out there who
wants revenge against the fast fam
here we go problems problems family
problems action sequences wow in a
franchise that's always trying to one-up
itself where it's like how do we get
bigger than the last movie well cars
versus submarine of course how do we get
bigger than that we'll launch people to
space how do we get bigger than that
unless you're spinning Donuts on the
moon or going to Mars how and that's
where this movie does differ I feel you
know like the fast movies I've gotten
progressively ridiculous the last couple
movies have been ridiculous but they
have that one thing that stands out you
know submarine space cars the case of
fast X is like every action sequence is
going to be
unbelievably ridiculous it's not just
one thing it's the whole movie is is
that one thing I mean the first real
action sequence in this film is a bomb
rolling through the city just crashing
into anything and everything never
losing momentum like it's the big ball
and fight club or something among that
ridiculous scenario are about seven
other ridiculous scenarios that happen
and I'm not even convinced that this
scene
is in the top five craziest things that
happen in this movie everyone just had
the Mario Superstar the entire time like
they shouldn't have lived through that
seven seconds later they shouldn't have
lived through that either but I feel
like in a world where the Fast and
Furious movies are kind of like the
Mortal Kombat games where it's like
We'll Kill characters off and then we'll
bring them back hey they're alive we're
tired of doing that so we'll just make
them invincible and live through [__] in
that there is a self-awareness that this
movie does have it leans into that
cheese in a way that not a lot of movies
do this is like in the writing room
there was every coked out producer that
Evergreen lit any 90s action film
whatsoever they were all like yeah this
works it worked for 10 years in the 90s
it can work for the 10th film here it's
kind of thematic and poetic in a way
when you look at the numbers that way
that said it still does run into that
sense of you never feel a sense of
danger because everybody's just doing
the most ridiculous [__] and living
through the most ridiculous [__] the
movie's enormous too just look at the
poster everybody's here almost anybody
anyway except for
DC's greatest super villain of all time
I say DC's greatest super villain of all
time because this dude killed Shazam
without even being in his movie that is
a Lex Luthor style kill shot right there
there's a big credit scene in here
already been spoiled online sure stuff
take that as you will I do feel like
that make credit scene was probably
filmed somewhere around last week just
logistically speaking but yeah the movie
is enormous that's the thing that holds
a movie like this back it's like you
have a lot of characters you don't
always know what to do with them the
newcomers of which there are a couple
Jason Momoa is the one to talk about
he's the Baddie he's the antagonist
going after the fast fam but I did like
what his character tied into in terms of
the story the events of the past I was
also surprised that Jason Momoa in the
movie I thought he was gonna be like
Aquaman you know like he just stepped
off of Aquaman 2's set came on to here
and just started filming and you know
he's Jason Momoa right but he wasn't
really like that I haven't seen Jason
Momoa like this he was a really
eccentrically crazy bad guy almost like
Jason Momoa was like I'm never gonna
play The Joker in a movie but I want to
play a villain kind of on the spectrum
of that he's actually what kind of made
it click more for me I was like
this is Saints Row it's this is a Saints
Row movie and he's a Saints Row villain
the movie ends off on a cliffhanger too
you know you've heard like oh fast X is
going to be the last it's like well
until fast X2 or fast XX or fast 11
whatever they're gonna call it one is it
doesn't just leave off open to a sequel
it leaves off like Mr Wharf
like I've said before you know you
better than I know you if you like Grade
B action films this is this is the most
expensive Grade B action nonsense with
cars I have ever seen this is a movie
that no
is unapologetically owns it and plays to
its fans Fast Five I think was the peak
of the of the heist Ridiculousness ever
since then I feel like there's been a
decline but if you've enjoyed the climb
of ridiculous and the fast franchise
you'll probably enjoy this because this
is that this is all that if you haven't
if you just haven't enjoyed them fast 10
is not going to be the one it's not
going to be the one you watched make you
gonna be like you know I had this
franchise rung until now I've seen the
light no I will say this I think this
movie would probably be a great time if
you're drunk yeah now it's a family all
right so fast X have you seen it what
did you think about it I would say
ranked it there's 10 of them I'm not
gonna make you work today but what's
your favorite and least favorite Fast
and Furious movies whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to say more
[Music]